bienvenue sur la page twitter de tv 78
en direct du vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines qui accueille
aujourd'hui le big tour le festival des
entrepreneurs un événement au niveau
régional mais surtout 50 chinois ou les
entrepreneurs de saint quentin en
yvelines vont être accueillis ici pour
démontrer leur pour présenter leurs
innovations et leurs activités en ce
moment c'est la préparation de cet
événement puisque l'ouverture au public
se fera à 13 heures inauguration prévue
à midi en présence du ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire je vous invite
à me suivre on va aller voir les
différents espaces alors il faut savoir
que le big tour et en deux espaces ya le
village des pays france qui est située
sur le parking à l'arrière du vélodrome
et vous avez ensuite une tente avec
saint quentin en yvelines qui est
présent ici vous avez différents espaces
dans cette tente on va aller les voir il
ya des espaces conférence vous avez le
planning des conférences que vous pouvez
découvrir cet après midi donc avec
différentes thématiques qui sont abordés
notamment la création d'entreprise les
compétences précieuses pour être recruté
la finance mme le financement de la
création d'entreprise ou le
développement d'activités et puis bien
évidemment le sport puisqu'on nous
sommes au vélodrome nationale vélodrome
nationale qui sera le site un des sites
olympiques du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines qui accueillera bien
évidemment les épreuves de cyclisme sur
piste donc un espace conférences qui se
situe sur ma gauche et puis à ma droite
vous allez pouvoir découvrir les métiers
de demain on va tout de suite s'y rendre
vous pourrez découvrir ça cet après midi
à partir de 13 heures comme je vous
l'indiquais donc métiers d'avenir avec
différentes entreprises des centres de
formation on va aller tout de suite voir
ce qui se passe alors ceux comme vous le
voyez ans et c'est en installation les
entreprises les acteurs de la formation
du territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines sont en train de s'installer
vous avez par exemple l'isi haïti on y
était présent l'autre jour sur le sky et
colisée haïti l'expert de la formation
du numérique situé à montigny le
bretonneux
on va avoir sur ma sur ma droite on va
voir sky one portal donc c'est une start
up spécialisée
dans le développement de solutions de
réalité virtuelle et on voit ici un
monsieur en train d'essayer justement
avec le masque de réalité virtuelle donc
l'une des start up que vous pourrez
découvrir cet après midi sur le big tour
à ma droite on a le campus des services
de l'automobile et de la mobilité situé
à guyancourt juste à côté du
technocentre renault spécialisée dans la
formation est bien à l'automobile à la
réparation cyclistes et ça tombe bien
puisque on est à côté du vélodrome
nationale
voilà une des grosses entreprises
spécialisées dans l'aéronautique est
présente sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines il ya trois sites
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est safran safran
équipementier aéronautique qui construit
notamment les moteurs d'avions et
notamment à guyancourt il ya safran
aircraft engines qui est spécialisé un
site qui est spécialisée dans la
maintenance des moteurs d'avion
on va avancer dans ce voilà dans ce hall
métiers d'avenir
ici vous avez l'école de 1600 l'école de
1600 qui existe depuis l'année dernière
c'est une école spécialisée dans la
formation à la cybersécurité on le sait
la cybersécurité c'est l'enjeu du 21e
siècle protéger les systèmes
d'information et vos appareils
informatiques est connecté on verra vous
allez pouvoir le découvrir cet après
midi à l'extérieur une démonstration de
hacking de véhicules connectés vous
savez très bien aujourd'hui les
véhicules et vos voitures sont de plus
en plus connectés et finalement ça
facilitent l'intrusion et le hacking de
ce genre de véhicule là vous avez une
autre entreprise grosses entreprises
présentes sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines c'est thales thales
spécialisée notamment dans l'équipement
du rafale il développe plusieurs
systèmes qui permet d kimm de qui écrit
par le rafale systèmes d'informations
systèmes de radar aussi
vous allez pouvoir faire du drone aussi
lors de ce big tour puisque là vous avez
un espace de démonstration pour faire du
drone
d'ailleurs on va lire on va les voir la
personne qui est sur ce stand voilà que
vous êtes en direct sur tv 78 sur notre
page twitter de tv 78 alors est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire sur cet espace
eh ben on va pouvoir s'essayer au trône
l'objectif pour nous c'est de montrer
que le numérique c'est un espace
d'opportunités et le drone c'est une
opportunité du numérique comme une autre
donc
l'objectif c'est d'essayer et de voir
décès naviguer voilà
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est il ya
beaucoup de perspectives en termes
d'emplois notamment et en termes de
perspectives d'activités de
développement au niveau des drones
des drones oui mais de tous les domaines
du numérique c'est-à-dire cybersécurité
community management web développement
web design donc on élargit enfin on l'a
on présente l'activité des drones mais
pour nous le numérique c'est bien plus
vaste que juste une activité donc on
veut montrer beaucoup d'aspects que
juste une seule activité aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup donc rendez vous à 13
heures le public pourra tester du coup
le drone
on va aller voir l'estac à l'estaca
école d'ingénieurs présentes sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
à montigny le bretonneux
alors on est en direct sur la page
twitter de tv 78 un mot qu est ce que
vous allez présenter aujourd'hui au
niveau de l'estac a de quoi bonjour à
tous je suis président de leo du coup
c'est une association spatiale de
l'école donc en fait le but c'est de
faire des petites fusées et des grandes
fusée les grandes fusée d'ici 2025 notre
but est d'atteindre 30 km d'altitude
entre temps ont validé palier
intermédiaire des briques technologiques
et du coup pour 107 par exemple de
fusacqs donc des fusées expérimentales
ces diffuseurs comme vous loyer qu'ils
font à peu près de deux mètres de mettre
10 et le but c'est d'être une expérience
à l'intérieur donc cette année on a
testé des systèmes embarqués non par
exemple gps c'est important de se
repérer et du coup on va arriver petit à
petit à d'autres technologies comme par
exemple des moteurs qu'on va fabriquer
nous-mêmes à l'école donc à l'école qui
nous encadrent avec le fab lab et des
endroits spécialement conçu pour ça et
donc du coup l'année prochaine on va
faire un essai statique donc au sol et
après on va essayer de mettre ça dans
une fusée est donc de plus grandes
dimensions 4 à 5 mètres pour 20 cm de
diamètre après tout ça vous fait ça sur
le campus de montigny-le-bretonneux oui
donc en fait on a les locaux principaux
de l'association qui se trouve à saint
quentin en yvelines et derrière un peu
plus loin au niveau de la zone de
trappes on a un local associatif énorme
et c'est là on peut faire tous nos tests
et des expériences vous par exemple
personnellement c'est quoi votre projet
professionnel
moi pour l'instant je pense m'orienter
vers les start up donc tu avec l'estac a
space odyssey donkey et les eaux nous
avons pas mal d'anciens qui viennent de
venturi spacer beatles donc est une
start up basée à reims est en fait ce
qui est totalement dans le projet de me
faire des micro lanceur pour en fait
mettre des charges de satellites
beaucoup plus basse donc le but serait
peut-être de trouver un stage là-bas
vous voyez comment évolue justement le
secteur du new space ou comme on dit en
europe le next space pour se
différencier d'elon musk et de space x
quand vous voyez cette évolution je
suppose que vous voyez énormément
d'opportunités et de perspectives pour
pour votre profil personnel oui tout à
fait c'est comme les preuves qu'ils
disent
il aimerait peut-être être à notre place
pour certains parce qu'en fait il ya une
telle effervescence discret au niveau du
monde spatial qu'on pourrait arriver à
des solutions donc pour que je vous ai
dit des micros au lanceur ou des
microsatellites qui répondent en fait à
une réelle demande et une réelle offre
au niveau du marché eh bien merci
beaucoup bonne journée voilà pourrez
découvrir justement les formations
proposées par l'estac a notamment alors
il ya le spatial mais aussi
l'aéronautique le ferroviaire toutes les
mobilités c'est une école d'ingénieurs
qui est situé donc juste à côté à à
montigny le bretonneux donc voilà les
génies de demain ils sont présents sur
le big tour et puis d'autres qui n'est
sans il ya des startups on va aller voir
différentes start up là vous avez hamad
à ma gauche le latmos et bien
l'observatoire
universitaire de l'université
versailles saint quentin on va aller les
voir vous allez on va leur poser
quelques questions bonjour alors le
latmos qu'est-ce qui va qu'est ce que va
présenter le latmos aujourd'hui sur le
banc alors moi je vais présenter plus un
accent lien avec un département dont
nous sommes en train de développer des
petits satellites petit satellite dédié
à l'observation de la terre et du climat
donc nous allons vous montrer quelles
technologies nous développons des
satellites et ensuite on va aussi parler
de quelques thématiques comme l'arctique
parce que nous observons les zones
polaires pour voir un peu les effets du
réchauffement climatique et ensuite on
vous montrera aussi des instruments que
nous avons à bord de la station spatiale
internationale
donc ici vous avez un exemple
d'instruments qui mesure le spectre
solaire
énormément d'activités en ce moment au
niveau de l'activité spatiale on voit
des observations sur mars avec notamment
curiosity c'est ça et puis vous allez
participer vous avez contribué à ce
projet le laboratoire participer oui à
cette mission et c'est quelque chose qui
est l'exploration de mars l'exploration
de l'univers c'est quelque chose de
fondamental donc le laboratoire fait
partie de cette aventure vous avez aussi
lancé dernièrement un nano satellites
alors nous avons lancé le satellite uvs
que ce soit ici vous avez une maquette à
l'échelle une qui représente ce
satellite donc il a été lancé le 24
janvier 2021 depuis la base de vente de
noms floride cap canaveral donc c'est un
satellite qui est dédié à l'observation
du bilan radiatif de la terre
hélas les projets futurs alors le projet
futur vous avez ici une maquette d'un
autre satellite que nous développons ce
satellite s'appelle inspire sats est
donc c'est un satellite qui est fait en
coopération avec des universités des
laboratoires de recherche internationaux
donc aux états unis à singapour à taïwan
il ya des objectifs multiples bon
évidemment on va à nouveau essayer de
résumer le déséquilibre énergétique de
la terre donc le bilan radiatif de la
terre c'est un paramètre clé directement
lié au réchauffement climatique on va
ajouter une carte électronique pour
faire du sondage du resf eric dans les
hautes fréquences ça permet de mieux
comprendre les couches de l'atmosphère
supérieur et ensuite on va aussi
développer des technologies annexes
comme de la détection wifi avec une
entreprise qui s'appelle oled comme on
fait travailler avec nous une multitude
d'entreprises locales à terme sr mattel
mais aussi des entreprises comme à driss
qui nous ont aidés dans le développement
de multi détecteur est multi paramètres
donc une véritable synergie entre les
différents insectes alors oui le ces
programmes ont un avantage c'est qu'on
arrive à un moment avoir une synergie
avec les acteurs locaux les industriels
et pour nous ce qui est fondamental
c'est de ré approprier alors une des
dernières barrières que nous rencontrons
c'est celle en lien avec les composants
électroniques on a beaucoup de
difficultés en ce moment pour faire
venir des composants évidemment les
puces viennent de taïwan 1 à plus de 80%
donc un des enjeux futurs je pense et de
donner les moyens au département à la
région au territoire d'avoir une
capacité de fabriquer ses propres opus
ses propres composants électroniques
donc tout un enjeu à la fois lié bon
évidemment à la recherche à l'éducation
à l'industrie et au couplage de toutes
ses composantes un des enjeux donc quand
il sera question lors de subic tour
parce que c'est l'un des enjeux avec on
l'a vu avec la crise qu vite merci
monsieur
merci beaucoup donc voilà le latmos
l'estac a vu des start-up aussi au début
de ce salon donc laisse le salon le hall
métiers de l'avenir qui sera présent au
bik tour ouverture à 13 heures au public
j'ai juste à vous dire que on vous
attend